there is a man
that i love
and that man
is not Marzia
its senpai *aka cryaotic*
*piano music*
(don't tell me that's Kirito)
*little fabulous twirl*
but that man doesn't even notice me
*poods leaves to stalk cry*
it is time to put on the big gloves
(Prepare your anus)
no more Mr. nice poodeepie
Time to use my PewDieCry Simulator.
ok bros
in this episode
we are going to kill
everyone
every one but senpai *sencry*
here we go there are some ways we haven't done it before
one is as sans
(U havin' a bad tym ryt about naw???)
YOU WILL ALL PAY
eugh!
Yeah
yeah thats right get fucked by my bone
(says when getting a boner, playing a trombone)
this is what you all pay come on guys lets play
*signs of insanity*
where are you guys Running
bitch
hoo hoo ho ho ohoh oh yes!
eugh
oh where did she go oh there she is omg she's spaghetti
wacky waving inflatable arm tube man
this
is
for not
giving me
grade
A
you fucking bitch
does anyone want a toast
*very high girly scream* its pewdiepie
shut up
Say your last prayer *shoots audible*
Bye-bye bitch.
euuuueh
Dance
bitch
dance
(U DO lick your mustache, LIAR!)
*eardrums bleed*
you wanna toast *ken does*
just calm down a little bit
their is another mode to fuck people over with
fuck yes
um excuse me
Have you ever tried anal fisting
what are you looking at
oh oh bitch went to space
*music plays*
oh shit look at that
eh lets take a pic of her panties
oh thats good
saved!
um excuse me can i have a moment from you to talk about our lord and savior
bitch
OhohoOHOH
i got you buddy :3
there it is i saved you Oh my god UM
you're disfigured for the rest of your life but it will be ok *no it won't*
you're in safe hands now
just fucking kidding
You're dead to me giraffe son of a bitch
giraffe son of a beach
*pewdiecry moans*
that got a little intense didn't it *no*
lets
lets have a nice cup of tea and think about what we did
maybe the best way to get to senpai *aka cry*
is not to brutally murder every one *nah really?*
maybe
we should just
talk to him
*dramatic music*
f that i got a last move
a last move epic enough to make senpai *cry* notice us
look at senpai :3
he is so beautiful
this is it I'm going to talk to him i love him
he's so
*pause*
handsome
oH nO
WhAt A trAgIty
thEy are aLl DeaD
boob ba doo ba doba oh its such a hard work now that should do the trick
phew oh oh oh it worked!
yes!
at last
Oh!
I've tried for 84 years
to summon this demon
*bom bom bom bom*
*pewdiecry moan*
oh Marzia
*ew*
*really felix. just stop*
hello teacher
*pewdiecry moan*
unlimited power*he is so high* *looks at her ass*
ah shit it is so late
i gotta go back to supper *back? did you leave it*
mom's gonna be super pissed if I'm not back home in time
"...Why can't we be friends?"
*you also killed my father*
alright bros that was another update of Yandere simulator
i love this game let me know if you want more updates i would love to give it to you
not, lol u thought
leave a like if you enjoyed watching I really appreciate it I'm so sick of saying it but its just a like
thats all ye gotta do
now thank you
and stay awesome*bros?*
subtitles by emilee reynolds thank you to all the others that helped edit these